[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire la loi contre la haine sur
internet
défendu par la députée la république en
marche laetitia via était adopté en
nouvelle lecture par la commission des
lois
elle sera confirmée demain en séance
très probablement avant de repasser
devant le sénat le 30 janvier et le vote
final aura lieu à l'assemblée début
février mais elle suscite nombre de
critiques de la part du conseil du
numérique du syndicat de la magistrature
ou de la commission européenne
alors pour en débattre nous avons invité
philippe cohen vous êtes avocat vous
avez fondé en 2014 respecte zone une ong
française de prévention positive des
cyber violence et de protection de
l'enfance est l'auteur de internet
contre l'internet avec un jeu de mot 50
propositions pour des tox et les réseaux
sociaux c'est paru aux éditions du bord
de l'eau est ce que vous êtes favorables
à une loi contre la haine sur internet
que ce soit cette loi défendu par
laetitia via on va en parler ou une
autre mais vous inviter à vos yeux est
ce que c'est nécessaire notre travail ça
consiste à travailler avec les victimes
avec les écoles avec les personnes qui
se font lyncher sur les réseaux sociaux
et quand on travaille avec elle on sait
qu'il ya pas d'autre solution que de
trouver une bonne régulation qu'ils
soient à jour de l'actualité de ski et
le lin chat sur internet donc ma réponse
courte c'est oui il faut une loi à jour
bien sûr oui alors benjamin bayart de la
quadrature du net est en retard mais il
va pas tarder donc on va passer au
suivant
philippe
la tombe oui avancé le wii wheel et
avancez encore le jeu par le promoteur
là parce que là philippe platon de
membres du modem investi par la
république en marche vous êtes devenu
député de la vendée en 2010 est membre
du groupe de travail sur les droits et
libertés constitutionnels à l'ère
numérique vous êtes opposés à la loi via
vous avez voté contre lorsqu elle a été
examinée en première lecture au mois de
juillet vous expliquerai pourquoi mais
est ce que vous pensez néanmoins qu'il
faut une loi une loi non une régulation
oui et cette régulation à mon avis elle
ne peut avoir lieu qu'au niveau européen
il faut qu'on ait une zone européenne
qui puisse avoir sa propre
réglementation et donc ça serait une
directive un paquet de directives plus
règlement européen qui permettrait
d'harmoniser l'ensemble de la
réglementation en europe n'est pas une
loi spécifique telle que celle là marc
crise vous êtes journaliste rédacteur en
chef de next imm'pact un site
d'information sur l'informatique et les
nouvelles technologies dont le slogan
est si tu ne fais pas demande et si tu
sais partagent une loi est-elle
nécessaire à vos yeux
c'est très simple je dirais oui tout
simplement et oui et cette loi existe
depuis bien longtemps on a la loi de
1881 sur la liberté de la presse et en
la loi sur la confiance dans l'économie
numérique qui depuis 2004 encadre cette
problématique là donc le paysage est
déjà bien bien rempli et c'est pour ça
que je m'agace assez assez facilement
lorsque j'entends
des politiques ou autres expliquait qu
internet est une zone de non droit ce
qui est une erreur fondamentale qu'est
ce que vous répondez cela film quand
même 1880 2004 nous sommes en 2020 la
réponse est dans la question
enfin ça dépend la loi sur l'école
gratuite privé gratuite laïque et
obligatoire elle jacques dossier
internet était même par eva blanc et en
2004 n'y avait pas de lynchage donc
aujourd'hui les technologies changent
des comportements évoluent aussi
il n'a jamais fait aussi mal vivre sur
les réseaux sociaux qu'aujourd'hui donc
oui il ya des adaptations à faire et on
est plus en 2004 non oui enfin je vous
en prie enfin on a le code civil de 1804
et ils fonctionnent encore aujourd'hui
enfin lorsqu'un texte est correctement
fait lorsqu'il est correctement ciselé
il permet de réguler et de de gérer des
problématiques qui se posent dans le
quotidien
bonjour benjamin bayart vienne me
rejoindre et qui permettent il permet de
réguler lorsqu'il est correctement
ciselés des problématiques actuelles et
après ça exige aussi des moyens les
moyens par exemple et je crois avoir vu
sur notre site que vous appeliez aussi à
ce qui est beaucoup plus de moyens
qu'ils soient dévolus à la justice
d'autorégulation mais je partage il
faudrait vrai justin bayard qui va se
mêler l'immédiatement la conversation co
fondateur de la croix de quadrature du
net association qui défend depuis 2008
les droits à la liberté et la liberté
d'expression sur internet vous êtes
également président de la fédération des
fournisseurs d'accès à internet
associatif vous est pour ou contre
pas forcément cette loi la loi via on va
en discuter mais une loi vous
semble-t-elle nécessaires pour contrôler
sur internet
il ya probablement des éléments qui sont
du domaine législatif qui serait utile
oui mais c'est pas seulement contre la
haine sur internet
je suis aussi d'avis qu'il ya un
contrôle du pouvoir des grandes
plateformes et c'est une question
structurantes là dedans c'est qu'il
faudrait pouvoir contrôler facebook
facebook a trop de pouvoir et donc
entre autres il a un pouvoir de nuisance
énorme par le fait qu'il permet dé
harcèlement qui permet des comportements
haineux et donc moi je suis d'avis qu'il
faut retirer du pouvoir à facebook et
cette loi lui en donne et c'est pour moi
un problème fondamental
on va en parler philippe platon faisait
intervention pour revenir sur ce qu'on
disait effectivement il faut moderniser
une partie de notre or notre législation
pour s'adapter à ce nouveau mode de
communication que sont les réseaux
sociaux mais transformés en
fondamentalement nos lois précédentes
qui gère la liberté de la presse et la
loi dans une zone de confiance telle
qu'elle avait été votée en 2004 ne me
semble pas être utile il faut qu'on
l'adapté aux nouvelles pratiques il faut
qu'on l'adapté à l'évolution
technologique on n'a pas à faire une
réforme de fond
si on abandonne la loi sur la liberté de
la presse si on y transige parce que
c'est un nouveau média on risque d'avoir
des surprises et ça a été extraordinaire
mon ciselé on aime jurisprudence
abondante qui est venu après qui permet
de solidifier de stabiliser notre droit
en termes d'expression et je pense pas
que au motif qu on a des nouveaux
réseaux sociaux des nouveaux outils il
faut absolument tout remettre par terre
alors on va voir sur les murs de ce
studio passé un certain nombre de
messages on va pas les laisser trop
longtemps parce qu'ils sont pouces avec
des contenus haineux mais c'est vrai que
ces messages là n'existait pas avant les
réseaux sociaux et avant internet c'est
à dire que quand vous envoyez je dis ça
au passé ce type de message dans les
journaux on ne les diffusez pas et si
ascendante de journalistes avaient envie
de tenir de tels propos le rédacteur en
chef
son avocat me l'avocat le service
juridique du journal lui disais non ça
n'est pas possible aujourd'hui ce type
de message passe en permanence sur les
réseaux sociaux
il est sont racistes violence sexiste et
ne sont rien des appels au meurtre il ya
à peu près dans tous les genres
est-ce que là encore on se dit est ce
que ça va vous n'êtes pas obligé de les
laisser traîner pendant deux heures ils
voulaient faire passer
est ce qu'il ya un moyen est-ce qu'il
était d'abord souhaitable nécessaire de
les faire disparaître
et est-ce qu'il ya un moyen autre que
l'une loi du type de celles de laëtitia
avait malgré votre présentation
je suis désolé tout petit peu biaisé oui
parce que vous confondez deux statues
ils sont importants vous confondez le
statut d'éditeur
celui qui va rédiger un journal et qui
aura un contrôle total sur ce qui va
être imprimé sur papier ou autre support
et vous confondez ce statut là avec
celui d'hébergeur un hébergeur c'est
quoi c'était un intermédiaire
intermédiaires techniques qui va
récupérer du contenu mis en ligne par
des internautes et qui va le diffuser au
plus grand nombre
voilà est imposée ou faire entendre
on va dire plutôt tendre la
responsabilité ont calqué la
responsabilité de l'hébergeur sur celles
de l'éditeur
c'est aussi ouvrir la voie à des risques
extrêmement important en terme de sueur
censure après je crois que je n'ai pas
fait un sondage avant l'émission mais je
crois qu'on est tous d'accord sur
l'objectif c'est à dire que la haine
c'est mal et ce genre de message oui ils
font saigner les yeux il n'y a aucun
souci mais on voit bien aussi ce que ça
prenait une nuit puisque déjà ils ont
déjà arrêté de les diffuser tellement
ils ont peur voyez cet arrêté de suite 3
600 actions voilà effectivement
l'autocensure philippe cohen est
immédiate
ce qui ce qui manque aussi ce qui ce qui
était compliqué de pouvoir inventer
qu'on soit en 1880 où en 2004 d'ailleurs
la loi de 2004
lehmann directive est là donc c'est une
directive qui a été écrite en 99 quand
on sent quand même qu'il ya qui a
beaucoup d'années qui sont passés et
donc à l'époque le concept de la
modération n'était pas aussi utile
n'était pas aussi avancé et modérée
n'est pas censuré le faire anticiper les
réponses qui vous qui vous qui vont être
faites
or aujourd'hui lorsque lorsqu'on a mal
sur internet il eu le temps de la
douleur n'a rien à voir avec le temps du
référé ou dut ou du contentieux au fond
et donc qu'il fallait je suis pas
monsieur laviani manama bien mais l'idée
c'est qu'il fallait trouver des
solutions alors je trouve qu'en
allemagne il ya eu un premier exemple
qui n'a pas été une catastrophe puisque
ça fait deux ans
que cette loi est en place et eu un
premier rapport qui est sorti au mois de
juillet et qui montrent que seulement
10% des contenus qui sont signalés sont
effectivement enlevé par les plateformes
c'est à dire qu'on est très loin de la
dictature et de la censure 10 %
seulement sont enlevés par le par les
plateformes on s'aperçoit que facebook
et twitter ont des comportements
différents
facebook a d'ailleurs été condamnée à 2
millions d'euros en allemagne
parce que ce n'était pas assez clair la
manière dont on pouvait faire des
différents signalements
mais ça montre bien que on n'est pas en
train de parler de censure puisque comme
c'est un débat qui va intervenir dans
cette
affectée avec ce studio je préfère
anticiper ce point là on n'est pas sur
la france il n'y a pas que ses trois
invités qui dénonce la censure
il ya eu quantité de d'associations y
compris y compris au plus haut niveau
européen qui ont dit risque de censure
de limiter la liberté d'expression
le premier risque c'est effectivement
celui là c'est que les fameux contenu
gris ceux qui sont pas manifestement et
ne vous avait présenté des exemples bien
gardé de sa cd4 et haineux qui tombent
sous le coup de la loi
je pense qu'il n'y a pas grand article
de la loi mais il n'y a pas grand chose
il ya des contenus qui sont en contenu
gris et cela vu la punition que les
réseaux sociaux vont avoir s'ils ne
respectent pas le process va faire que
de faire dans leur modèle économique
ils vont pas prendre le risque et donc
ils vont systématiquement coupé dès
qu'il y aura ce n'est pas ce qui s'est
passé en allemagne
c'est ce pas pourquoi ça se passerait 10
ans qui a commencé en allemagne il n'y a
pas les mêmes sanctions non plus il n'ya
pas le même c'est presque démontrer à
une amende de 4 % du chiffre d'affaires
mondial vous pensez bien que facebook et
twitter ça va faire mal dans leur compte
donc ils ne vont pas prendre le risque
donc il ya un risque de sur censure et
on ne suis pas le seul à le dire la
plupart des associations disent le
l'union européenne a dit qu'il y avait
une question sur le montant des
sanctions
donc il faut se poser la question de la
proportionnalité et le vrai souci sur la
partie semble sûre sur censure il est là
il est sur les contenus gris ceux pour
lesquels quand quelqu'un prononcé propos
à la télévision ou ailleurs quand il ya
une action auprès des tribunaux qui est
faite de pour cette personne là les
juges quelques mois après 10
maintenant ces propos là il n'y avait
pas quelque chose qu'il va être
sanctionné
or aujourd'hui s'est confiée aux
plateformes se relaxer le sait le point
central de la loi s'est confiée aux
plates formes elles doivent faire le
ménage dans les 24 heures dès qu'on leur
signale un contenu litigieux
manifestement les manifestants oui mais
à paris je pose une question simple 1 on
est très obsédé par la défense de la
liberté d'expression depuis les
attentats contre charlie or on ne cesse
de réduire cette même liberté
d'expression depuis à peu près la même
époque
aujourd'hui il y aurait pas eu
d'attentât contre charlie les délais
caricatures de mahomet
en passant sur facebook elle serait ce
qu elles seraient immédiatement censuré
au nom de la nouvelle loi contre les
propos haineux je pense pas moi j'ai un
gros problème là dedans qui est clos en
fait ce que ce que propose la loi c'est
de transférer un mélange entre les
pouvoirs de police les pouvoirs de
justice à facebook et à toutes les
plateformes aux grandes plate forme dont
celle là mais pour moi les grandes
plateformes ont déjà trop de pouvoir et
en fait les propos haineux y a pas que
sur facebook qui m'emmerde sept mois les
propos racistes quand c'est décrit dans
les tribunes du stade des princes ça me
fait chier au moins autant que sur
facebook quand c'est les remarques d'un
policier dans un commissariat
je trouve ça au moins aussi grave que
quand c'est un petit con sur twitter et
curieusement un policier qui tient des
propos racistes dans le commissariat
la police n'a pas 24 pas pour le
sanctionner en fait elle ne sanctionne
jamais ou alors il est un bluff c'est
pas sûr mais ça c'est exactement le même
type de problème c'est que notre société
affiche le fait qu'elle ne veut plus des
propos racistes des propos sexistes des
propos homophobes et elle ne le fait pas
ça je sais pas quels sont les moyens de
la plateforme pharos à laquelle on peut
dénoncer des contenus haineux je pense
qu'ils sont faibles
je pense que la loi n'a pas prévu de les
augmenter très dans les dents les
morceaux de loi dont j'avais déjà
discuté avec laeticia via il ya le fait
par exemple de créer un parc est
spécialisée sur les questions de
numérique
ça c'est un très bon point et je pense
que tout le monde est pour si ce mot si
ce parc est doté des moyens qui vont
bien si les policiers qui mène ses
enquêtes ont les bonnes formations pour
faire les réquisitions dans les bonnes
formes
j'ai vu passer l'info il ya quelques
jours il ya des pays qui ont 80 % de
réponses de twitter la france 40 et des
poussières
pourquoi parce qu'on s'est pas posé les
questions parce qu'en fait les questions
sont mal posé et quand on pose mal la
question la plateforme répond pas ça
part en contentieux sa part en conflit
sur du droit californien qui a peu de
chances d'aboutir
juste parce que nos policiers savent pas
formuler des questions comme il faut
savent pas
avoir les bons éléments techniques etc
sa demande à être formés je peux
comprendre que le policier du
commissariat du coin
il sait pas forcément comment faire ça
il est peut-être épaulé par une
direction parisienne mais cas par cas
pas que ça à faire
voilà avoir ça c'est typiquement
d'éléments de la loi qui est intéressant
à voir un parc est spécialisée dans le
numérique pour pouvoir saisir beaucoup
plus vite les plates formes etc
moi je trouve ça très bien benjamin
bayart la loi de 1881 au fond demandait
non pas au juge forcément de faire la
police mais d'abord au rédacteur en chef
du journal à l'éditeur du livre
aujourd'hui on va dire à rédacteur en
chef à la télévision parce que la loi
s'applique de la même manière il n'y a
vait intervention du juge qu'à partir du
moment où une de ces personnes n'avait
pas fait son travail à ce moment là avec
quelqu'un qui portait plainte mais au
fond cela fonctionnait très bien
ça a sans doute un peu aseptisé
uniformiser les propos ça c'est
exactement ce qu'a expliqué marc tout à
l'heure sur la différence entre éditeurs
et hébergeurs quand le patron du figaro
est responsable de ce que le figaro
imprime fait imprimer il est éditeur
mais l'imprimeur l'imprimeur lui c'est
pas son problème
lui dit à moi j'ai imprimé le figaro
j'ai imprimé l'humanité et j'ai imprimé
lacroix est ce que ça raconte c'est pas
mon problème il facebook c'est la
primeur pour vos facebook est dans une
espèce de position mixte il n'est pas
vraiment l'imprimeur parce qu'il n'est
pas vraiment neutre
facebook qui choisit de mettre en avant
des contenus qui font le buzz
c'est en fait les deux tonneaux elle ne
les fait remonter parce que ça fait
parler parce que ça fait ça fait
critiquer ça fait crier ça fait du bruit
et donc ça amplifie le bruit on facebook
a un rôle c'est lui qui met en avant ses
contenus là plutôt que du renom mais ça
c'est pas intéressant c'est pas
pertinent autrefois la presse écrite ne
relayait pas les propos racistes mais
les propos racistes il existe enfin
gérer suffit d'aller dans n'importe quel
café en france depuis 1820 et des propos
idiots on entend juste il n'était pas
relayée on peut relayer et donc facebook
a un rôle les plages les grandes
plateformes
rôle de relais de grosses caisses de
tambours pour amplifier ces trucs là
c'est ça je veux les tenir responsables
qui d'exister nom de sa classe mais
c'est comme ça c'est la faute à la
police c'est là où l'index n'est pas
suffisant dire qu'il ya des avancées
dans le texte il ya deux avancées et
vous en avez pointé une qui est le
parquet spécialisé pourquoi pas il
faudrait qu'on est en face des
magistrats juges spécialisés
là aussi qu'ils puissent répondre dans
un délai qui correspond à ce qu'est
cette nouvelle technologie
il y avait une chambre comme ça pour la
presse dans les espèces en tout à chaque
fois qu'il y avait un jour alors chef de
l'état obs était là il ya une deuxième
avancée c'est le fait de la voir faire
du signalement 700 indirects par des
associations pour les mineurs qui ne
serait pas en capacité de le faire
ça c'est une trêve c'est une avancée
alors je suis pas d'accord avec la
rédaction de laëtitia viard on
s'expliquera demain sur un petit mot qui
change beaucoup de sens dans l'ain dans
le texte mais c'était nécessaire parce
que des enfants non des démineurs n'ont
pas forcément envie de demander à leurs
parents représentants légaux de faire un
signalement surtout quand ça touche à
leur sexualité à centre de choses pour
lesquelles les parents n'ont pas être au
contraire c'est très important et les
associations sont là pour ça aussi il ya
un point que la loi touche et sans le
régler c'est le problème de du des
contenus qui vont être répercutée en
permanence christchurch par exemple
c'est l'exemple le texte ne permet pas
de traiter ce problème là on a on a eu
des vidéos de l'attentât de christchurch
qui ont été envoyés à partir d'un
endroit du monde ils sont reliés partout
dans le monde
le texte de laëtitia ne permet pas
d'enrayer ce certes ruitz et facebook
fort c'est bien ça la véritable date il
faut sauver l'attentât de nouvelle
zélande
il est filmé en direct et diffusées sur
facebook la s'est interrompue
relativement rapidement les sites mais
il ya des des centaines de milliers de
copies et à ce moment là que dirait la
loi avia dans ce cas là elle rend
responsable le facebook du fait qu'il ya
des copies qui continuent de circuler
oui sauf que sauf qu'elle va le rendre
responsable sur ce qui se passe en
france et on sait pertinemment que c'est
quelque chose qui va venir de partout
dans le monde et donc aujourd'hui on a
une véritable difficulté c'est pas une
loi en france dans quelques années la
qui permettra d'éviter sur la vidéo de
ma recherche sur la vidéo de crise
cherche l'exemple et très bien parce que
on va imaginer un cas un médium tout à
fait respectable diffusé un extrait de
cette vidéo et ils associent cet extrait
un tweet avec un lien vers un article
qui décrit le contexte cette vidéo son
caractère déguelasses horribles ignoble
atteinte fins attentatoires à la dignité
de la personne humaine et aucun souci
là-dessus
le problème c'est qu'un algorithme c'est
assez con on est plus proche du
grille-pain que des êtres humains et que
va faire la ligue au rite si on a une
base une liste noire de contenu à
éradiquer le prime d'algorithmes c'est
que la mise en contexte là
contextualisations d'un retrait c'est
pas évident c'est pas évident d'être
d'ailleurs lorsqu'un juge va travailler
sur ce sujet là celui ci va quand on est
parti va jauger et il va mesurer
doit-on porter atteinte à la liberté de
communication d'information doit-on
rassurer cette nécessaire sécurité
publique voilà il vit faire un travail
mais l'algorithme lui il n'est pas en
compétence est le point central sur la
proposition de loi a bien il réside dans
l'article l article 20 dit quoi on a une
liste de contenu qui devront être
supprimés dans les 24 heures comme vous
l'a très bien dit par les plateformes
qui dépassent un certain seuil de
connexion des grosses plateformes on va
dire ces contenus là donc devoir être
retirés à 24 heures aucun souci on a vu
quelques-uns
je vois ça je suis hébergeurs on le
signale je supprime bon par contre les
contenus gris que signalé philippe la
tombe
là aussi on a eu un cas particulier
puisque le problème de la loi c'est que
la loi prévoit une sanction couperet si
on ne retire pas un contenu
manifestement haineux manifestement
problématique mais on n'a pas un
dispositif tout à fait similaire en cas
d'abus de retrait en cas de sur censure
je suis désolé j'utilise le mot interdit
en ga 2 en cas de retrait donc d'un
contenu qui n'aurait pas dû être retiré
que va faire la plateforme lorsqu'elle a
un doute
normalement la logique juridique
pourrait se dire si j'ai un doute sur le
la licéité d'un contenu est bien dans la
mesure où j'ai un doute celui ci n'est
pas manifestement illicite dont je
conserve
voilà le problème c'est que l'algorithme
fera le contraire l'algorithme un
contraire mais sinon aussi la logique
humaine la logique des services du
service compta du space compte à kidira
maintien s'ils retirent pas ce contenu
tu risques jusqu'à 1,25 million d'euros
d'amendé
c'est le panier sur veille juridique
dans à peu près tous les médias
aujourd'hui vous disent tout le temps
retire retirons cg voilà donc il ya
cette logique de parapluie à savoir je
retire pour essayer de sécuriser ma
situation
elle est à craindre c'est là où on a une
problématique serait contenue gris et on
n'a pas cette fille qui valence exact je
dis bien équivalence exacte entre la
sanction d'un d'un défaut de retrait et
la sueur censure d'un contenu que sur la
durée légale texte ce qui aurait permis
de le rendre qu'ils veulent
10 pts et puisqu'on nous oblige à rôtir
en 24 heures la contestation de ce
retrait devrait être fait dans les 24
heures avec un motif et une sanction
pour avoir le pendant et on n'a pas le
pendant dans sa cellule quand l'ordre
est d'accord avec ça oui puis juste pour
compléter ce que ce que marc dit
également c'est que l'article 1 pour
être clair alors c'est pas juste un
algorithme qui va crawl et comme on dit
les des messages c'est que c'est il
s'agit d'un article qui fonctionne sur
sur signalement
attention c'est à dire qu'il faut qu'il
y ait quelqu'un qui s'en plaignent
lorsque par exemple un animateur
christophe beaugrand se plaint de
menaces de mort parce qu'il est
homosexuel et que c'est dit avec des
avec des insultes que vous avez
peut-être vu sur twitter il le signale
et aujourd'hui il dit c'était au 5
janvier il dit les règles de la
communauté twitter ont refusé d'enlever
ce contenu donc là on est vraiment sur
quelqu'un par exemple l'actuel c'était
il ya quinze jours qui se fait attaquer
la phrase c'est pas gris là les phrases
que vous verrez sur twitter et que
l'exemple de son père en par rapport à
ce que je disais oui mais c'est ce que
vise cette fois et cette loi elle vise
que les contenus qui sont pas gris elle
vise les contenus qui sont manifestement
illicite
après avoir été signalé donc s'il ya
aucun algorithme automatique comme un
grille pain qui feraient travailler à
l'avance et d'ailleurs il y avait une
demande que nous avions fait qui
consistait à dire et qui a été retenue
en partie
c'est à ce que y ait des delà de la
modération en tout cas un examen qui se
fasse à la main à dire avec des êtres
humains est ce qui fait partie des
requêtes qui ont été faits et je rejoins
ce qui a été dit par philippe sueur sur
la partie procès c'est à dire que le
texte est améliorable pour ça qu'on
compte sur vous avec les prochaines
étapes qui sont prévues par le parlement
parce que c'est vrai que plus on peut
avoir des capacités de faire appel de ce
qui va être enlevée avec un délai court
et qui permettent à près à ce que le
juge soit saisi
ce que ne sait pas d'aller déposséder le
juge de ses pouvoirs souverains mais
c'est plutôt qu'il y ait une réponse
dans un délai dont on sait que le juge
ne pourra pas être le garant parce que
24 heures
je suis désolé mais en tant que
praticien de la procédure
c'est pas comme ça que ça marche mais
m'a référé d'horreur
c'est pas en heure ça se compte en
général c'est qu'un jour un mois minimum
et ensuite ça passe vite au fond et là
ça prend un an deux ans et en fait les
victimes ne sont pas entendus moi ce que
j'aimerais c'est que c'est qu'on pense
aux victimes dans ce débat il compense
pas juste à des débats un peu
désincarnées mais le débat n'est pas
désincarnés parce que le débat il est
vraiment centré sur la question des
contenus grille donc effectivement vous
pourrez toujours là c'est pour quelques
jours et secoué comme un drapeau comme
un épouvantail des tweets absolument
abjecte je n'ai aucun souci dans leur
retrait dans la fonction de leurs
auteurs je n'ai aucun problème et je
n'ai aucun problème dans la mise en
cause de l'hébergeur si celui ci a mal
fait le job
j'ai aucun problème là dessus moi ce qui
m'importe aussi dans cette problématique
celle équilibre entre cette nécessaire
lutte contre les infractions pénales
parce que ce sont des infractions
pénales
cette vieille loi que vous jugiez des
dieux est quasiment noir et blanc telma
dix ans pour le lynchage sur internet la
loi d'une formidable mais ouais mais sur
le linge à sur internet serait l ancien
les classes prépas jour matière de
droits d'auteur que vous connaissez
aussi on a des textes qui sont très
anciens une seconde vie cette loi cette
proposition de loi prévoit tout de même
que la plateforme met en oeuvre des
moyens technologiques homme derrière
vérifie sur les sur abu le csa
aujourd'hui dans les moyens
technologiques des moyens technologiques
pour traiter de ces contenus là donc
c'est sûr que si vous faites un peu mais
faut contrôler f sur le texte en
question vous trouverez pas grippe a
mais chercher technologique et vous
aurez moyens technologiques y va par
exemple donc les caricatures de mahomet
ça ne passerait pas je suis pas juge je
suis pas magistrat je suis pas un
hébergement
si vous parlez avec cette loi a priori
ça dépasse les 70 comme ça que la
solidité de service juridique de chaque
plateforme
on pourrait se dire mieux ces acteurs là
on sont correctement équipés google a
une armée de juristes facebook au xi e
et aussi mais traiter ces questions là
en 24 heures
lorsque vous avez des millions de
messages qui surgissent chaque jour et
c'est difficile on fait une pause en
france des belges juste après
[Musique]
arrimé des pays africains à l'euro c'est
une évidence bêtise la france a intérêt
à maintenir des français parce que selon
le crr instruments qui sont la
protection de ses intérêts économiques
en afrique
l'écho c'est quelque chose qui était
fait entre pays africains et sur lequel
la france et l'europe avait pas grand
chose à dire en question de la date fixe
avait dit non mais c'est est ce que
c'est d'avoir les mêmes prochain le
sujet aujourd'hui en afrique c'est pas
d'avoir une inflation à 2%
ces espèces de critères qu'on impose
alors c'est des critères de tirer entre
guillemets d'économies matures à des
économies qui sont en développement cet
idiot
[Musique]
mais oui
dans ce livre on vous découvre
extrêmement proche de votre mari un
couple très fusionnelle à ce vivier un
peu dans la peur avec tino quai des
menaces oui d intimidation comme brûler
les locaux oui mais un assassinat
vraiment gênant je pense que j'y croyais
pas ceux qui ont été assassinés étaient
les politiques de journal il était l'âme
de ce journal et oui ils ont tué charlie
je voulais pas que tignes où ce soit une
victime
je voulais pas que son nom soit associé
à huy qui nous la victime de charlie je
voulais que l'on se dise à tignes où le
grand dessinateur c'est ça qui est bien
avec un artiste c'est qu'un artiste ans
qu'on publie son travail l'artiste est
vivant
[Musique]
nous reprenons notre débat sur la loi
via contre la haine sur internet avec
philippe cohen de respecte zone avec
benjamin bayart de la quadrature du net
philippe la tombe qui est député modem
de vendée et marc crise le rédacteur en
chef du site next inpact restons sur le
grille puisque vous l'avez très bien dit
c'est surtout sur le gris que les
questions vont se poser
il ya des contenus ouvertement et ne
d'autres on peut imaginer qu'ils seront
à la fois signalé et éradiquer alors
soit par les algues au rythme soit par
le service juridique des plateformes
mais il ya aussi tout ce qui est pas
clair par exemple quand on traite les
gens de violeurs ou de pédophiles sur
internet
est-ce que c'est du contenu haineux
aujourd'hui il ya énormément de gens qui
sur les réseaux sociaux très fiable et
un match de fou dit allen si on ramène
kolinski de pédophile et violeur est ce
que ça va être considéré comme de la
haine sur internet ou pas c'est une
bonne question en fait et
et du coup est ce que tous les gens qui
critiquent les moeurs de gabriel
matzneff se retrouveraient censure et
c'est une excellente que c'était une
question s'impose des cigales end romain
paulhan est en fait diffamation c'est
c'est une élimination
c'est précisément pour ça que pour moi
l'élément clé c'est à l'erreur
fondamentale de cette loi est de vouloir
donner du pouvoir aux plateformes
je pense qu'il faut retirer dire qu'une
des bonnes façons de traiter ça était de
dire pour moi le le truc que j'ai en
tête depuis un petit moment sur ces
sujets là c'est ce qu'on appelle du
nautisme notice serre que je vois un
contenu qui me plaît pas clic je dis ça
c'est pas bien ça rien à faire là ça je
pense que c'est illégal
la plate forme prévient le comte
émetteurs du contenu en disant voilà on
lui a été signalé comme étant illégal
est ce que vous souhaitez le maintenir
et si oui vous engager et là on a deux
transactions qui sont notés serre que la
plateforme est capable de dire on a
signalé que le contenu était
probablement illégale est l'auteur du
contenu a dit je maintiens mes propos et
donc je m'engage ou et du coup ça ces
deux transactions là ces deux éléments
là peuvent être transmis automatiquement
à la justice avec les informations
disant voilà bob il a publié sa
henry a signalé que ce n'était pas bien
bob a dit qu'ils comblent qui maintenait
on transmette sa tel quel à un juge qui
lui décidera et ça ça me paraît beaucoup
plus intéressant sire que les que des
plateformes en fait est une obligation
de prendre en compte les notifications
de commencer à constituer si on veut un
pré dossier qui est qui a notifié quoi à
quel moment pourquoi en prétendant à
quelle infraction et c'est en fait
prépare le dossier pour la justice et
puis l'auteur du contenu a dit qu' il
maintenait qu' il
il estimait qu on compterait une
obligation des plateformes vis-à-vis de
ce qu'elles font
elles n'ont pas écrit les propos haineux
elles les ont diffusés en tant que
diffuseur la zone responsabilité et puis
on crée une deuxième obligation pour moi
qui ai l'interdiction de censurer ces
interdictions de retirer le contenu
s'est pas séparé plateforme de retirer
le contenu soit c'est l'auteur qui fait
ou merde
j'étais un peu excité hier soir j'ai
écrit des mines ça va pas et qui de
lui-même l'enlève ce qui arrive souvent
ce qui arrive quand même que sur un coup
de tête on écrive un peu de la mer
depuis on se dit ce n'est pas forcément
très fin mais c'est pas aux plateformes
me l'enlever gersois c'est l'auteur qui
n'enlève pas ce qu'il s'est rendu compte
qu'il avait fait des bêtises
soit c'est la justice qui n'enlève mais
moi je suis pas d'accord pour que ce
soit les plateformes je veux pas leur
donner ce pouvoir là je veux pas que ce
soit facebook qui soit chargée
d'appliquer la loi
écrire la loi il ya une brassée d'élus
dont ces noms c'est le boulot et
l'appliquer il ya des juges dont c'est
le boulot et je veux pas que ce soit
facebook face à jégun la question surgit
chiens est-ce que les gens qui traitent
de la foi qui traite de gabriel matzneff
woody allen où roman polanski deux
violeurs pédophiles vont se retrouver
sans autre ou de la loi de 1881 on est
dans la dans la diffamation
non mais bien des accusations parfois
sérieux via la présomption d'innocence
il est accusé il n'a pas été condamné
c'est une diffamation éventuellement est
donc là on tombe dans un texte qui est
prévu et donc c'est pas du csa ca
ressort effectivement de la 17e chambre
correctionnelle 6,7 à paris et c'est un
cas classique et donc effectivement si
quelqu'un accuse quelqu'un avant qu'il
soit accusé par un tribunal
c'est une affirmation que ça ses
couverts par le droit
c'est potentiellement une diffamation
qui peut s'offrir de la preuve contraire
l'exception des exceptions vérité donc
je pourrais six ans jusqu'à ce qu'il
soit condamné ensuite sûr sûr sûr les
autres alternatives se sait bien aussi
qu'on sorte de la loi dure et les
sanctions et notre association respecte
zone s'intéresse en fait à autre chose
s'intéressent d'abord et avant tout à la
prévention au travail avec les écoles et
lorsque vous avez des sites internet qui
disent ben moi je m'engage à ce qu'ils
aient une charte du respect je tends ce
qui permet à des censures et tout en
disant ben si si vous êtes sur un espace
de respect on vous rappelle que le
respect ce sont des choses qui ont une
valeur alors le respect c'est le fait de
pato bob c'est le fait de et est en fait
ce qui permet de pouvoir créer un
système sur l'engagement et si quelqu'un
déroge à cet engagement
effectivement ça passe dans dans le
droit positif en fait c'est une manière
aussi de de pouvoir sanctuariser
internet en disant on peut être sur
internet sans que sans que ça déraille
parce que effectivement beaucoup de gens
oublient que sur internet les lois du
monde réel sont aussi applicables dans
le monde numérique et donc c'est pour ça
qu'on travaille sur la prévention
positive en disant ça c'est un espace
qu'on va sanctuariser au même titre que
l'école s'il sa tombe
autre exemple mais j'aime bien les
exemples comme ça on voit au moment du
mouvement balances ton port quelqu'un
qui aurait été mise en cause sur
balances ton corps ton corps pardonnez
moi pour signaler signalés çà en disant
que c'est à propos haineux qui le
concernent et qui veut que ce soit
censuré et aurait-il obtenu gain de
cause
est-ce qu'on censure est toutes les
accusations le résultat risque à mon
avis serait là oui qu'on se conçoit dans
une sur censure parce que il n'ya pas
il y aurait beaucoup de signalements et
que le nombre de signalements à un
moment attirera l'attention du service
juridique de la plateforme twitter de
twitter en l'occurrence et qu'ils vont
dire dans le doute
comme on a beaucoup de signalements
n'enlève tour est long et on verra après
c'est le véritable problème c'est aussi
de cette fois c'est le renforcement du
pouvoir économique des grandes
plateformes c'est que elle elle ont les
moyens aujourd'hui de concevoir des
algorithmes avec des bases de données
base de données de mots contextualiser
de mots tout court mais aussi d'image
qui systématiquement vont être utilisés
par leur système dit de modération qui
vont faire que ils vont avoir une avance
technologique par rapport à des nouveaux
entrants qui font qu'à l'arrivée il
pourrait tuer toute la concurrence dire
que cette loi peut leur donner un
pouvoir économique supplémentaire ce qui
pose ce qui pose un souci c'est pour ça
qu'on a plusieurs on avait tenté et on
là dessus on s'est appuyé aussi sur les
travaux qui avaient mené la quadrature
sur la question de l'interopérabilité
il y à des réseaux alternatifs
mastodonte en est un exemple ou des
personnes qui étaient sur les réseaux
classiques se sentant harceler sont
sortis des réseaux classiques ont créé
leur propre système collaboratif avec
des règles qu'ils se sont fixés avec une
modération qui l'ont qu'ils organisent
eux-mêmes ils peuvent en sortir sans
perdre leurs contacts et aujourd'hui la
véritable difficulté c'est le pouvoir
économique de facebook et twitter quand
vous sortez de facebook et twitter vous
perdez tous vos contacts vous perdez la
capacité de communiquer avec ces
personnes là est une forme de censure et
aussi pour un ensemble de personnes de
restreindre leur compte twitter
on va le voir moi je léger l'exemple en
vendée d'un élu qui se représente qui a
coupé l'accès à son compte twitter pour
éviter que des listes concurrentes
puisse avoir des informations et réagir
aux informations qu'ils publiaient voilà
et aujourd'hui on parle de ça le texte
de laëtitia bien il parle aussi de ça il
parle de comment est ce qu'on va faire
sur les réseaux sociaux pour avoir accès
à l'information pour la coupe et pour
éventuellement contre se re concédé vous
serez conférer un pouvoir économique et
c'est ça qui me gêne aussi dans ce texte
là au delà de la sueur censure ça pour
moi les questions d'interopérabilité des
vraies questions de fond
la question comment on sanctionne les
comportements mauvais est pour moi
toujours un signe d'échec quand on en
est à sanctionner les propos racistes ou
homophobes
ça veut dire qu'on a des brochettes de
gens racistes et homophobes et qu'on
veut juste qu'ils ne disent pas en
public
oui on peut pas non plus le remettre à
des électrodes dans l'oeil non mais je
trouve que c'est vachement intéressant
de se demander pourquoi notre société
produit ça parce qu'on a toujours
produit depuis l'origine des temps
auquel on produira toujours on va
toujours pas toujours dans les mêmes
proportions et pas toujours dans les
mêmes quantités
il ya des tas de petits éléments jrc ans
quand on donne l'exemple de quand on
considère comme normal un comportement
gens quand on considère par exemple que
la violence ou les propos haineux sont
normaux ils tendent à se développer dans
la société quand on les casse cou ou les
considère comme anormaux ils tendent à
moins se développer typiquement
l'endroit où on apprend le harcèlement
c'est dans la cour de récré et le fait
de traiter ces questions là dans la cour
de récré est un bon moyen de faire en
sorte que ces - lieu après donc tout
tout ce qui relève de la prévention et
de comprendre pourquoi ces comportements
surviennent je trouve que c'est
extrêmement intéressant et c'est
pertinent et puis la question de
l'interopérabilité c'est vraiment pour
moi une question clé marc sur plein
d'autres débats autour du numérique plus
celui sur les questions et de traitement
de la haine c'est comment on fait pour
retirer du pouvoir à ces plateformes un
de leurs pouvoirs étant d'être un point
central c'est une forme c'est un
monopole
et donc quand on retire ce pouvoir là on
voit apparaître plein de fonctionnement
différent par exemple ce que ce que
décrivait fils du plâtre tombent sur le
seul réseau mastodonte ce sont des
dizaines de nous des centaines voire
plusieurs milliers maintenant de
serveurs interconnectés entre eux
chaque serveur est administrée selon ses
propres règles selon les règles d'une
communauté cirque les gens ont choisi
d'aller sur tel serveur exactement comme
vous choisissez votre fournisseur de
mail moi j'ai choisi d'héberger mon mail
sur ma machine perso à la maison
d'autres ont choisi d'utiliser tel ou
tel prestataire technique mais tout est
un tout est interconnecté je peux
envoyer des mails aux gens qui sont sur
d'autres plateformes mais les règles qui
s'appliquent à ma boite mail sont mes
règles à moi ça ça change tout en termes
de traitement des propos
typiquement du harcèlement quand vous
êtes membre d'une communauté je pense
avec tous mes potes trans qui se font
emmerder mais en permanence et sur deux
sont des choses qu'on n'imagine même pas
et bah se regrouper entre personnes qui
ont les mêmes types de problèmes sur une
toute petite plateforme où il ya que
quelques dizaines de comptes
n'importe qui qui vient pour embêter se
fait virer immédiatement cela là pour le
coup la censure là dessus elle est
assumée elle est voulue elle est dure et
c'est fait exprès et ça ça marche mais
mais parce que c'est du traitement
humain serre que ce sont des petits
groupes humains qui traite humainement
un problème essayez d'exceller l'érable
pour quelqu'un qui fait de la politique
qui est amélie torah ou qui il a besoin
de s'exprimer devant tout le monde orma
certain nombre d'entre eux sont donc
littéralement harcelés on va leur
reprocher sur les crimes imaginaires
soit des engagements soit la couleur de
leur peau soit leur religion soit
l'origine de leurs parents etc et ils
sont harcelés
wima mais pour le coup les personnages
publics sont harcelés tout le temps et
en fait ils sont d'autant plus harcelée
qu'ils tiennent des propos clivant mais
je vois bien enfin j'ai suffisamment de
personnes qui me suivent sur les réseaux
sociaux pour voir ce genre de choses là
moi même
dis que je dis des choses qui déplaisent
bush obligé de laisser filer les
mentions parce que j'y peux rien c'est
très rare les gens soient très agressif
avec moi mais de toute façon s'il était
très agressif ou menaçant je ne peux pas
à saisir la police elle ne ferait rien
c'est là où je voulais en briller à
nouveau
enfin c'est vraiment magnifique que de
faire des lois pour pour résoudre la la
la haine en ligne ses fruits la connerie
humaine
enfin je le mouvement est appréciable en
par contre ne pas avoir une adéquation
des moyens d'être des moyens dévolus à
la justice là ça me pousse à me pose
problème
durant le grand débat chaire emmanuel
macron bercy avait publié une note qui
était vraiment très intéressante et qui
montrent que sur 1000 euros de dépenses
publiques 4 euros vont dans les poches
de la justice 4 euros 4 euros dans les
poches de la justice mais la justice n'a
pas seulement traiter la haine en ligne
heureusement malheureusement jsba mais
elle doit gérer absolument tout des
crimes au sens pénal du terme notamment
quatre routes donc c'est rien c'est des
poussières des poussières de poussière
de poussière de poussière d'argent
public et en fait c'est là où le piège
ce temps c'est à dire que on arrive avec
un texte qui nous dit que brad a sion le
juge
évidemment on va intervenir après a
posteriori il sera toujours là tapi dans
l'ombre prêt à surgir et à sanctionner
la plateforme qui aura absolument fait
n'importe quoi mais le problème c'est
que les moyens de justice sont pas là et
on le voit encore aujourd'hui dans les
rues tous ses avocats kyi qui se
peignent leur situation au regard des
réformes actuelles et ce poids là il est
quand même centrale
il est central dans ce débat donc je
choisisse éducation parce que
l'éducation c'est d'ailleurs par des
dispositions dans la loi mais tout à la
fin une médiation qui sont très timides
qui sont très parlants nous on pourrait
dire la même chose parce que les
professeurs eux-mêmes sont déjà
suffisamment sollicités s'il faut en
plus qu'il fasse de la delà de
l'instruction civique en ce qui concerne
ils sont ils sont aidés par le monde
associatif et ce ne sont pas des
idées qui manquent nous ce qu'on pense
justement pour répondre à votre point
savoir comment est-ce qu'on mutualisent
la formation c'est que a un autre sens
c'est un mélange entre du présentiel la
déformation en classe ou dans également
avec les entreprises puisqu'elles sont
aussi intéressés par savoir comment est
ce qu'on se fait moins de mal entre
autres collègues par exemple ou lorsque
vous avez des clients qui sont qu'ils
deviennent très agressif avec des
conseillers qui font face au public
comme on dit j'en parlais récemment avec
des personnes qui sont par exemple dans
des boutiques de téléphonie
tendez dans des banques vous avez de
plus en plus des des incivilités
ça commence avec des lettres majuscules
puis ça finit avec de menaces voire même
ce sont des personnes qui vont
travailler et vis-à-vis des des
consommateurs et donc ce que ce qu'on
préconise c'est à la fois des tutoriels
c'est à dire des modules courts qu un
peu comme comme des permis internet mais
qu'ils soient des permis de pouvoir
aider à du dialogue
ce qu'on organise aussi sont des
concours de cyber éloquence dire qu'on
permet à tous ceux qui sont équipés d'un
portable partir de l'agent général de 11
ans veut près ça commence à descendre à
9 ans malheureusement aujourd'hui mais
de pouvoir participer à des concours
d'éloquence en ligne c'est à dire dire
que parce que vous avez parfois des
jeunes qui se trouvent très éloquent à
partager la photo d'une ex copine nu et
qui pensent que ça a fait rire les
copains et donc nous ce qu'on explique
c'est que si on remet un peu le curseur
au bon endroit
on explique que ben con qu'on peut faire
rire différemment et que ça c'est pas du
tout aux drôles
c'est juste contre la loi c'est contre
le respect et surtout ça ne s'effacera
jamais parce que lorsque quelqu'un est
harceleur lorsque quelqu'un à linge sur
les réseaux sociaux
ce qu'ils oublient souvent ou ce qu'elle
oublie c'est que c'est ineffaçable ce
qui veut dire que c'est un peu comme un
péril que vous pourrez plus effacés
justement est-ce que cela ne renforce
pas la conservation des données ce
contre quoi l union européenne le bea
cité nature la quadrature du cercle
alors oui ce fut nette ginette brunel
pardonnez moi mais c'est
en fait l'histoire de conservation des
données sur la can on se base la
conservation des données de connexion
qui permet de savoir ce que qu'ils
faisaient quelle adresse ip a été
utilisé oui mais ça donne beaucoup plus
que ça en fait ça donne la
géolocalisation de votre téléphone sadi
où vous êtes camp avec qui est ce que
vous êtes en train de faire et pourquoi
vous y aide
avec qui vous êtes en train de discuter
à ce moment-là et reconnaissance faciale
et la conservation des données
c'est un truc de fou et à l'heure
actuelle les obligations de conservation
permettent à l'état de surveiller sa
population le la cour de justice de
l'union européenne a dit que c'était pas
bien
elle l'a dit deux fois dans deux arrêts
de grande chambre une manifestement la
france s'en fiche elle souhaite
continuer à espionner sa population
s'est elle n'est pas la seule
non non il ya beaucoup d'autres états
européens qui veulent faire ça mais de
la même manière que la cour de justice a
dit qu' il fallait pas mettre les
députés en prison et que l'espagne a
répondu qu'elle s'en fichait voyez c'est
le droit et les choses bizarres ces
temps ci comme ça qu'il faut l'écrire
avec une main tremblante
c'est pour ça que je fais et aux mille
jeunes ces projets de loi avec une étude
d'impact solide l'avenue tapas qu'on l'a
pas parce que c'est une proposition de
loi et c'est pour ça que soulever
oui mais je suis tout petit module privé
et soulever soulevé l'urgence la
procédure parlementaire
ce qu'a fait le gouvernement afin de
limiter le jeu de navettes et ben c'est
pas super judicieux la preuve c'est que
la commission européenne est intervenue
dans plein débat français et j'ai sorti
les observations enfin une priorité de
régulation moi j'ai pas une concurrence
c'est simplement un respect la pyramide
des textes la commission européenne a
rappelé simplement qu'il y avait une
direction plus attendre cinq ans ça la
question
si vous êtes une victime vous n'attendez
pas cinq ans pour être protégés et une
directive je suis la relation entre
cette approche là ça fait 30 ans que les
que le travail n'est pas fait le travail
de prévention de travail de police ça
fait ça fait 30 ans que le travail pour
comprendre 25 ans non mais j'ai sur
cécile et les clés aux plateformes
rappelle quand même que dans les idées
parlement dans la proche des bidules
haineux il ya encore 150 femmes par an
qui meurt sous les coups de leur
conjoint et que quand elles vont se
plaindre commissariat le commissariat a
autre chose à faire
nous irons n'est pas sur des problèmes
de contenu haineux dans la police qui
fait pas son travail sa cdc des
problèmes de formation de moyens
d'accueil de traitement on est très au
delà
quand on sera capable d'accueillir ces
victimes là comme il faut peut être
qu'on pourra aussi recevoir les plaintes
de gens qui se font harceler parce que
je vous assure que actuellement
quelqu'un qui se fait harceler qui va au
commissariat pour se plaindre il se
passera rien c'est pourtant la loi
prévoit que moi dans la police mais
c'est techniquement endroit tout existe
juste les policiers n'ont pas les moyens
n'ont pas la formation
les juges n'ont pas les moyens les
procureurs n'ont pas les moyens n'ont
pas que ça à faire ils sont pas notés là
dessus les préfets ils sont notés sur le
nombre d'étrangers expulsés ils sont
quatre ils sont pas notés sur le nombre
de crimes racistes sanctionnés voilà
tout ça c'est actuellement il faut rien
faire je dis pas que pour rien au vert
mais je dis qu'il va falloir commencer
par mettre en marche et administre avec
un ticket avec un numéro
la question de la tombe ce type de sujet
on a bien vu que le rhdp des d'origine
européenne avait pris avait donné dans
ce nid dans l'espace européen
une norme qui est du coup et regarder un
peu partout été regardée au japon comme
étant intéressant là aussi sur ce type
de sujet un gino allemande et d'une loi
française qui avait 48 c'est que ça met
un peu de temps mais d'un côté ça permet
aussi d'utiliser les bonnes techniques
ou les bonnes solutions d'hygiène
ils viennent des villes qui viennent des
pays on parlait de ce qui se passe pour
les féminicides aujourd'hui on va on va
s'intéresser en france à ce qui se passe
en espagne depuis depuis plusieurs
années pourquoi est ce que aujourd'hui
on ne fait pas ça au niveau justement de
de d'internet de la régulation pour
avoir quelque chose qui soit normes et
au niveau européen avec des modalités
parce que vous savez bien qu'on peut
avec des directives avoir un peu de
d'ajustement mais est-ce qu'on était
obligés d'aller nous avec cette loi là
tout seul sans prendre vraiment en
compte ce qui s'est passé en allemagne
parce qu'il ya quand même eu des cas
particuliers de sueur censure en
allemagne et pourquoi est-ce qu'on a
effectivement utilisé une proposition
noir un vecteur législatif avec peu
d'études d'impact avec une urgence et
avec on le voit une opposition entre les
deux chambres l'assemblée entre les arts
et le sénat était la servette y gagne
toujours
cette opposition elle veut quand même
dire quelque chose elle veut quand même
dire que yahia qu'elle il ya il ya une
vision qui peut être différente et cette
vision différente
on aurait pu arriver à quelque chose en
commission mixte paritaire et on voit
qu'on n'y arrivera pas parce que d'un
côté il y avait une obligation de moyens
d'autres et d'interopérabilité de
l'autre côté une obligation de résultat
et la volonté de sanctionner en 24
heures
donc il aurait fallu qu'on a et on voit
bien que ce texte cristallise beaucoup
de choses pour moi il ya un élément clé
là dedans qui est alors que tout le
monde est d'accord sur l'objectif à
atteindre
il est surprenant qu'on n'arrive pas à
obtenir un texte qu'on voterait à
l'unanimité dans les deux chambres
et ça pour moi c'est un signe que le
texte est mal ficelé mais est-ce que ça
dépanne signe de la vème république
autrefois léthale à londres devrait
public la première époque non mais tu es
si bois pour les feuilles économistes -
à la fin était d'accord sur la vème
république au vote un texte à la
majorité la majorité suivante des faits
le texte je prends pas quand on a
affaire à des textes qui sont non
clivant ça arrive assez régulièrement
que ça passe gentiment et je reviens des
textes qui dure de pendant 50 60 80 ans
s'entend comme du temps de la troisième
république
je pense qu'on est encore capable de
faire ça mais pas sur ce pas sur des
lois de cette qualité là typiquement le
travail qui a été fait en 2004 sur la
mgen qui a été un précurseur la loi sur
la confiance dans l'économie numérique
de sa position européenne n'ont
absolument pas c'est le contraire
les textes européens restent de 2006 et
à 10,99 la directive de 99 et les
banques témoin de miettes
attendez je vous interromps parce que
j'allais les débats sur le sujet ont été
très très long et en fait la france qui
avait commencé certains débats en 96 sur
le sujet a réussi en 2004 avec laquelle
que
audace et intelligent qui a servi depuis
deux piliers a pas mal d'autres morceaux
de droit et compris les morceaux de
droit européen sur la séparation entre
le rôle des hébergeurs entre le rôle des
gens qui transportent les contenus entre
le rôle d'éditeur et comment ça
s'articule etc
et c'est resté relativement stable parce
qu'il nous reste quelques minutes qui va
contrôler les opérateurs les plateformes
pour savoir si elles vont bien ce que le
nettoyage c'est ça l'art et c est ça qui
est prévu pour le gendarme de la
télévision est ce que le gendarme de la
télévision le csa le csa traverse une
crise existentielle depuis bien
longtemps
pourquoi parce que celui ci était
effectivement moyenne pas qu'on évoque
ce rôle de képis mais il est
effectivement le gendarme de la
télévision et de la radio pendant bien
longtemps
internet un peu bouleversé les choses
un tout petit peu bouleversé les choses
et on pensait d'ailleurs que la
télévision comme la radio elle être
complètement diluée ce qui est
d'ailleurs un petit peu le cas dans les
pratiques diluée dans cet univers
complètement fou qu'est le web est le
csa quelques mois faisait est ce qu'on
le conserver est ce qu ont modifié bon
c'est l'option numéro 2 qui a été choisi
avec une extension de ses pouvoirs
donc on est passé d'un organisme d'une
autorité administrative dédié à l'audio
visuel à un organisme qui doucement est
en train de déployer ses
c'est elle ou ses griffes à l'encontre
ban de pans entiers d'internet notamment
des vidéos sur youtube ou dailymotion
peu importe seront bientôt contrôlé par
le ce est ce quand bien même sont elles
généré uniquement par utilisateur en
fait pour revenir à la question vraiment
fondamental de ce texte
et pour que peut-être les ceux qui nous
regardent comprennent bien sans être
féru de juridisme c est ce que il est
judicieux que de confier le pouvoir de
régulation de vitesse sur l'autoroute
a20 si oui ou non voici qu'on le
rappelle ainsi que l'exploitant des
autoroutes payantes en partie marquée
notamment par les ag2r gpd a institué le
fait que dans chaque pays européen il ya
des cnil enfin des équivalents de cnil
et qu'elle ait une vision européenne en
pouvant se regrouper aujourd'hui le csa
est une autorité qui est franco
française
on n'a pas l'équivalent et on n'aura pas
l'équivalent dans les autres pays
européens avec ce pouvoir de sanction la
fin donnait des sanctions qui peuvent
aller jusqu'à 4 % de chiffre d'affaires
mondial pour à facebook et twitter c'est
fabuleux c'est énorme
l'autorité de la concurrence ça fait
jusqu'à 10%
je trouve ça fou et sauf que là on est
sur quelque chose qui ne touchent pas ce
qu'ils ne touchent pas du droit de la
conclure droit de la concurrence il est
aussi européens en grande partie là
c'est quelque chose qui est franco
français vous vous imaginez bien que ce
pouvoir de sanction là va faire que les
plateformes pour essayer de se conformer
à ce que va dire le csa le plus possible
donc ça donne un rôle au csa importants
dont il aurait fallu qu'on discute au
niveau européen puisque ça va nous
rendre un peu et solides derrière ça va
ça va surtout appliqués pour les futurs
d'hébergeur ils sont installés dans
toute l'europe de connaître la loi
française et les finesses des lois
françaises son application pour
respecter la loi
la future loi via la future loi via si
ces plateformes se dirigent ou dirigent
leur leur communauté vers la france y
d'animaux falcone l'émission se termine
ce que je devrais dire en dernier lieu
c'est d'avoir une pensée pour ceux qui
lorsqu'ils sont affectés n'ont pas le
temps de faire un débat qui dure une
heure lorsque lorsque vous êtes affecté
serre que lorsqu'il ya un bombardement
qui se fait sur votre nom avec votre
image avec des conditions qui peuvent
ruiner une vie et avec le nombre de
personnes qui se suicident
j'aimerais juste qu'on ait une pensée
pour ceux qui sont objet de ces
lynchages et qui se disent mais pourquoi
est ce que on débat au pendant autant de
temps sur une possibilité de pouvoir
signaler faire enlever et faire en sorte
que je puisse sortir dehors et pouvoir
respirer et donc c'est pour ça que même
si la loi elle n'est pas parfaite
au moins qu'on lui reconnaisse le fait
qu' à une empathie
c'est le mot du respect et de l'empathie
qui se fait jour
je crois que c'est pour ça qu'il faut
pas être vent debout contre les progrès
pour la défense des victimes
je vous remercie tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à cette émission merci de nous
avoir suivis rendez vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et